you guys do it there's Pilate good good
Steve you know when you're working on a
movie that long you can't help but stuff
underneath right I want to start by
saying how much I enjoyed the movie and
how I know it played well because all
the kids in the theater were silent
which is a sign that everyone was having
a really good reform factor low yeah
they didn't leave and they weren't
talking great purely nice is when jobs
do people know that when we do our
preview screenings that we have cameras
on the audience
and we actually note that squirm I got
to tell you something my first question
is what would be some what would people
be surprised to learn about the making
of small foot yeah that fits in right
that was perfect yeah well that it
changes a lot over the course of five
years like a whole lot well how long to
take it makes more food well small flat
from soup to nuts was about six years
six years hey like so a lot of element
arty I feel like honored to be in small
foot because so much work goes into
these movies like in the Lorax and the
I've done a few of them you know the
talkies and Hercules have done a bunch
of them but you realize the amount of
work that goes into a man an animated
movie is staggering it's like so great
and it's great when it comes when you're
looking around you seeing kids laughing
and having a good time and enjoying it
that's that's what I've reward I don't
think what people realize when they
watch one of these is that nothing
exists nothing so if I ever say oh can
they fly on a glider here
they don't have a glider in the front
warehouse sure it has to be made on a
computer it has to be colored it has to
you know some a lot of people it takes a
lot of hours to actually make these
things so nothing exists nothing for
everyone today I'm gonna be playing
something called get to know your small
foot cast or director okay so what TV
show would you love to guest spot on and
what TV show would you love to guest
direct It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
love to do a guest on
but you know it's one of my favorite
shows gonna work out the Des Moines I
think we can make that happen
what I like to guest direct yeah Curb
Your Enthusiasm oh do you have a
favorite sci-fi or fantasy film The Day
the Earth Stood Still
from the 50s yes I'm making sure yeah oh
they did a remake yeah they did oh the
first one right at the black-and-white
totally yeah yeah absolutely my favorite
sci-fi film or fantasy or I'm a big fan
of The Princess Bride actually totally
works I love that Fatou
do you own a lot of Nicktoons do you own
any movie or TV show props for either
they do a few things anything you want
to share edit penguins umbrella I have a
spider from James in the Giant Peach I
have a Hutt from chicken mom I have a
monk from chicken I have a piece of the
peach from James and the Giant Peach and
these are all movies that I worked at
totally I'm riddled with envy on all of
course stuff what is the background
photo on your phone
oh here's mine it's it's embarrassing
because I have three kids and it's only
one of them and my dog is actually don't
have a photo right and um I have to get
going but real quick what's the TV show
you watched
have you watched any TV show more than
once all the way through like bent like
a TV show that I've watched morning
whole series we watched it more than
quills Seinfeld Sopranos there we go
thank you both so much and seriously
congrats morphism very nice
you